so there's a big push in the u.s senate
to do something about so-called gun
crime so if you had a map of gun crime
that is crimes committed with guns
crimes which people died by gunshot you
would notice that they are clustered
in cities that's where the overwhelming
majority of gun crime takes place
but the senate isn't trying to do
anything about that instead democrats
have decided this is a perfect
opportunity in the wake of school
shootings to disarm you and the amazing
thing is
mitch mcconnell the head republican in
the senate is on their side completely
and he's rounded up a group of 10
republicans who can help him so the
backbone
of this package of legislation they're
trying to get through is something
called a red flag law and in one
sentence a red flag law would allow the
government to confiscate your firearms
without even charging you with a crime
much less convicting you of one so are
these republicans well the lead is john
cornyn of texas and the amazing thing
about john cornyn is he admits he
doesn't care about gun crimes committed
by actual criminals we know this from a
piece today in axios and we're quoting
senator john kennedy asked cornyn during
one lunch quote are we focused on gang
violence and inner city murders
and the responses no we're not focusing
on that
well if you're not focusing on that
why are you doing this exactly
we don't need to guess about where gun
crime comes from
here's a montage of some of the crimes
that john karen and cornyn can't be
bothered with
[Applause]
a ring camera in the neighborhood
captured the back and forth of gunfire
as panicked teenagers ran through the
street it's happened 26 times in just
one week a string of robberies that all
begin and end the same way nypd video
showing one of them where a team of
armed suspects riding in a dark-colored
mercedes-benz or volkswagen passat
suddenly stopped their car jumped out
flashed their guns
robbed their innocent victims get back
in the car and drive off washington
state alone has seen a record 85 armed
robberies at cannabis stores so far this
year this employee was shot six times
so crime is a complicated thing but the
crime spike that we're seeing now is not
complicated at all prosecutors across
the country are refusing to enforce laws
that we already have
and when you do that crime spikes so if
you're the united states senate if
you're john cornyn from texas supposedly
free state of texas you'd probably want
to do something about that
but no john corner has decided to take
guns from lawful gun owners and if
there's one reason you vote republican
it's to prevent that so it's not
surprising that john cornyn is very
unpopular with republican voters watch
his reception today at the texas
republican convention listen for the
booze
so let's take our country back
starting with congress in november
thank you
god bless you and may god continue to
bless our great state of texas
subscribe to the fox news youtube
channel to catch our nightly opens
stories that are changing the world and
changing your life from tucker carlson
tonight